m
tu es
bonsoir bonsoir à tous bienvenue vous
l'avez compris un seul titre ce soir à
la une de votre journal la mort de
michael jackson la star planétaire s'est
éteinte hier après un moment de
flottement et d'informations
contradictoires sur son état de santé
le chanteur a été officiellement déclaré
mort tard dans la soirée il a succombé à
un arrêt cardiaque dans sa maison de los
angeles
claude son père la nouvelle a fait le
tour du monde en quelques minutes
michael jackson est mort la star ait
décidé officiellement 14h26 à los
angeles
il était 23h 26 en france sur ces images
le corps du chanteur transporté de
l'hôpital à l'institut médico légal de
la ville
la rumeur courait depuis quelques heures
c'est son frère aîné qui est venu devant
la presse
annoncé officiellement la disparition de
l'artiste
oh mon dieu c'est dur mon frère
légendaire roi de la pop michael jackson
jim robb ce jeudi à 14h26 a probablement
d'une crise cardiaque à son domicile
vers midi michael jackson se trouvait
chez lui dans une maison qu'il louait
depuis quelques mois dans un quartier
chic
vers 12h30 les secours sont alertés
lorsqu'il arrive
le médecin personnel de michael jackson
est déjà en train d'essayer de le
réanimer mais ce pour le prennent en
charge
il continue les massages cardiaques dans
l'ambulance michael jackson est conduit
dans un des plus grands hôpitaux de la
ville
ici pendant plus d'une heure les
médecins vont se succéder pour essayer
de vanille mais la star en vain au même
moment des centaines de fans
alerté par les télévisions affluent vers
l'hôpital je ne sais pas quoi penser
j'ai entendu dire qu'il a eu une crise
cardiaque jeudi les petits syndicats les
médecins n'ont pas réussi à le sauver
je ne sais pas qui ça paraît irréel
je n'arrive pas y croire j'espère
vraiment que tout ce qu'on dit n'est pas
vrai pendant plusieurs heures les fans
vont se rassembler autour de l'hôpital
l' annonce officielle du décès l'est des
etats-unis sans voix a new york les
américains restent figés devant les
écrans de times square
toute la nuit à travers le pays les
admirateurs du roi de la pop vont se
rassembler par petits groupes tous
s'interrogent sur les causes de la mort
du chanteur
les autorités viennent d'annoncer qu'une
autopsie était en cours mais les
résultats des analyses toxicologiques
devraient prendre du temps
selon certains médias américains la
police recherche activement le médecin
personnel de michael jackson
en attendant d'avoir des nouvelles plus
précises
les fans rendent hommage au chanteur
la nouvelle génération est prête et elle
salue l'artiste et direction los angeles
où l'on retrouve notre envoyé spécial
bonsoir alain de chalvron on vient de le
voir ce soir le site internet qui a
annoncé le premier la mort de michael
jackson dit que la star aurait pu
succomber à une surdose de médicaments
administrés un peu avant par un médecin
vous avez des informations là-dessus
écoutez michael jackson était un peu il
perd le hip hop gandrille ac quand je
dis un peu c'est un peu plus qu'un peu
d'ailleurs il absorbait chaque jour une
quantité invraisemblable de médicaments
a commencé par une piqûre de morphine
dit-on quotidienne ou quasiment
quotidienne mais aussi des vitamines
pour se doper des somnifères pour dormir
des antidouleurs divers et variés un
traitement pour la peau et puis il
n'avait pas une hygiène de vie modèle il
avait beaucoup tiré sur la corde avec
des opérations de chirurgie esthétique à
répétition et enfin il mangeait très peu
il était quasiment anorexique
alors tout ça explique où il fait un
cocktail un petit peu détonnant et c'est
pour ça qu'on recherche effectivement
son médecin celui qui presque gb tous
ces médicaments
c'est pourquoi aussi on fait une
autopsie mais vous savez le paradoxe
marie c'est que d'après ses proches en
ce moment michael jackson était plutôt
en forme
il était excité à l'idée de remonter sur
scène après une décennie noire avec des
deux me succès commerciaux les scandales
de pédophilie etc
il était expliqué excité mais aussi
stressé le stress ça peut être aussi une
explication de sa mort subite
oui vous parliez de votre psy alain à
l'instant qui devrait donner un peu plus
d'indications et d'information d'ici
quelques semaines environ huit semaines
comment expliqué alain alors que la
planète entière rend hommage à michael
jackson que barack obama le président
américain ne se soit pas encore exprimé
oui c'est fait c'est un silence un peu
assourdissant il faut bien le dire parce
que ça fait maintenant quasiment 24
heures alors il ya un décalage horaire
c'est vrai avec la côte est enfin tout
de même maintenant ça commence à devenir
un petit peu bizarre alors c'est un peu
dans le style je dirais quand même de
barack obama qui tourner sept fois sa
langue dans sa bouche avant de parler et
qu'on le veuille ou non
michael jackson était un personnage
controversé avec certains dans la
communauté noire qui lui reprochait
d'avoir voulu à tout prix se blanchir la
peau et dans le fin fond du pays des
gens qui étaient encore persuadé qu'il
était bien pédophiles on va revenir
évidemment sur tous ses aspects les plus
lumineux comme les plus sulfureux merci
beaucoup
alain de chalvron envoyé spécial de
france 2 à los angeles au roi de la pop
star planétaire de la musique noire et
de la musique tout court
depuis ce matin les expressions souvent
clichés sont utilisés sans compter pour
revenir à la fois sur le destin funeste
tragique de michael jackson on va y
revenir mais aussi sur la carrière de
celui qui était déjà de son vivant une
légende est avant tout un génie abdellah
mostefa
ça crève les yeux et les oreilles aussi
la voix le groove tout est déjà là
alors que les gamins de son âge traînent
leur salopette dans les cours d'école
michael jackson va fréquenter plateaux
télé et scènes du monde entier
72 l'olympia à paris l'adolescent de 14
ans n'a que légèrement muet le leader
des jackson five des prêts pour une
carrière solo 79 avec l'album off the
wall
michael jackson entre définitivement
dans la cour des grands
ouais quatre titres se place au top 10
américain du jamais vu dans le meilleur
reste à suivre
80 de l'album thriller ressembler une
compilation de tubes
michael jackson est alors à son zénith
aucune difficulté à réunir une brochette
de stars autour de cette chanson
caritative qu'il cosigne avec lionel
richie
besson
m
michael jackson via leur ses plus belles
and artistic escorté tel un chef d'état
l'hystérie partout où il passe géniale
mélodiste danseur hors pair il règne
sans partage sur la planète pop
cours particuliers de moonwalk à la star
du basket michael jordan
nous sommes en 91 et avec l'album
dangerous michael jackson montre qu'en
matière de tubes
il y en a encore sous le pied dans les
années 90 la métamorphose va s'accélérer
tandis que la pelouse blanchie la
réputation se ternit
comportement étrange affaire de moeurs
production plus fade
michael jackson va devenir l'ombre de
lui même ses apparitions se font rares
comme lors de ce gala en 2006 où il
peine à chanter
pourtant le 5 mars dernier des milliers
de fans voulaient encore croire à
londres lors d'une conférence de presse
surréaliste
michael jackson venait leur annoncer une
série de concerts pour cet été cinquante
dates qui devait renflouer les caisses
de la star déchue
la dernière apparition publique d'un
monstre de la pop qui laisse derrière
lui des dettes et un sacré héritage
musical philippe manoeuvre bon sort bon
ce merci d'être avec nous est rédacteur
en chef du magazine rock and folk vous
êtes grands spécialistes de la question
jackson on vient de voir ce sujet ce
qu'on peut imaginer que les concerts les
dettes tout à coup michael jackson se
serait sentie submergée terrifié par
tout ça oui parce que ce retour était
très attendue quoi est-ce qu'il était en
état physique d'assurer ce retour mois
les dix dernières années j'ai vu des
photos de lui dans un fauteuil roulant
emporté par ses gardes du corps est en
très mauvais apparence occupé la scène
comme michael jackson cdsn de 60 m haies
c'est un spectacle total alors ce qu'ils
pouvaient faire deux heures de concert
dans ces conditions ce qui pouvait faire
cinquante concerts
question vous l'avez rencontré on va y
revenir tout à l'heure qu'est ce que
vous pouvez dire de plus ce soir de
mieux que tout ce qui a été dit depuis
ce matin il ya des choses magnifiques au
été dit je pense que votre émission fait
beaucoup de bien aux gens tout le monde
a plein de questions a envie de partager
un grand moment souvenant du danseur
souvent du chanteur ce magnifique ténors
moi j'ai envie de dire peter pan est
mort c'est un mythe qui vient de
disparaître c'est aussi bizarre que ça
c'est peter pan qui nous a quitté et il
a laissé derrière lui évidemment un
chambard pas possible mais une musique
merveilleuse vous restez avec nous
philippe manoeuvre
on va y revenir tout à l'heure avec vous
qui l'avez rencontré les réactions sont
venues du monde entier des stars madonna
denis ne pas s'être arrêté de pleurer
depuis hier évoquant le monde qui a
perdu l'un de ses plus grands mais sa
musique continuera de vivre
elizabeth taylor l'ami de toujours se
dit trop bouleversée pour s'exprimer
pour liza minnelli michael jackson aura
révolutionné le show business
paul mccartney
qui a chanté en duo le célèbre tube the
girl is mine salue un homme enfant au
talent immense michael jackson ce sont
quarante années d'une carrière unique
dans l'histoire 750 millions d'albums
vendus dans le monde et autant de femmes
antoine gaveau planet michael jackson du
nord au sud et d'est en ouest
à mesure que le soleil se levait les
fans du monde entier ont rendu hommage à
leur idole comme ce sosie mexicain la
nuit dernière
michael était tellement l'important dans
la vie que j'ai changé physiquement même
mon enfant s'appelle michael même
émotion ce matin en angleterre ou encore
devant l'ambassade des états unis à
moscou ça fait mal c'était un grand
monsieur
qu'il repose en paix à pékin on se
souvient surtout de michael jackson
icône pop et occidentale en pays
communiste la musique son rythme ces
dons seront eu un impact très fort ici
au moment où la chine s'ouvrait au monde
son travail était aussi symbolique
serbie ghana et aux philippines cette
radio a consacré sa journée d'antenne à
l'instar des messages même s'il ne
connaissait pas l'homme tous adoré sa
musique
un hommage célébré jusqu'en plein océan
indien par ces soldats américains n'y
croit pas il ne devait pas mourir
ce n'est pas réel en 91 michael jackson
chante i'm the world et voulait guérir
le monde
en quarante ans de carrière il l'a en
tout cas en goûter et même chose en
france évidemment où les fans ont appelé
à un grand rassemblement sur le parvis
de notre dame où vous vous trouvez pour
france 2 jean françois feer et et la
foule est immense bonsoir mari vous le
voyez sans doute il y a en effet
beaucoup beaucoup de monde sur le parvis
de notre-dame de paris un millier de
personnes au moins pour michael jackson
et les fans continuent d'affluer en ce
moment même les premiers sont arrivés
tout à l'heure en milieu d'après midi
alors que le rendez vous était fixé à 19
heures c'est dire si le besoin de se
recueillir est important ils sont venus
avec des t-shirts des banderoles des
fleurs également
et des fleurs également excusé excusez
moi est en tout cas c'est un hommage à
ces dignes pas d'excentricité
on échange des réactions on chante on
danse et les fanaux prévu d'ailleurs de
se retrouver tout à l'heure en
discothèque
en tout cas ici ce soir on n'évoque pas
du tout les ennuis judiciaires de la
star ni ses problèmes de santé
on parle seulement de l'immense artiste
qu'était michael jackson écoutez
quelques réactions enregistrées tout à
l'heure quand on fait un deuil comme ces
ménages point qu'on a besoin d'être avec
des personnes
tu comprennes un peu ce qu'on est en
train de vivre
michael jackson pourquoi lui par une
autre je sais pas j'ai commencé à
traduire ses chansons et je me
retrouvais parfaitement dans ses textes
et m'a beaucoup aidé pour m'en sortir à
une période de ma vie donc je suis là
aujourd'hui pour lui rendent hommage et
remercier pour ce qu'il a fait
inconsciemment parce qu'il laissait pas
noyer pour moi pas mal de chanteurs
danseurs américains vont compter sur lui
c'était comme la basse plus et c'est
comme la base des artistes il y avait un
tout s'est caractérisée qui faisait de
lui michael jackson ça qu'on les mène
on l'a vue de d'une vision assez noir
précédemment depuis 2005 et ce qu'il
mérite franchement non aujourd'hui moi
je vois que du positif nous a donné
quelque chose et c'est ça qu'il faut
c'est ça qu'il faut voir le lycée c'est
tout
même si cet échange il est devenu blanc
et pour moi il était toujours été dans
notre petit noir a donc gêné mais je
l'aimerais jusqu'à mal là pour ses
réactions recueillies par jean françois
feer et sur l'esplanade de la cathédrale
de notre-dame et l'ondé de choc s'est
aussi répandue sur la toile michael
jackson et ce soir numéro un des ventes
de disques sur internet c'est aussi la
ruée chez les disquaires il faut
rappeler que la discographie de michael
jackson c'est une vingtaine d'albums
avec les jackson five entre 1969 et 84 9
entre 72 et 2001 en solo off the wall
thriller bad constituant à eux seuls
trois recueils de chefs-d'oeuvre et de
tubes planétaires que l'on télécharge
donc depuis cette nuit dans le monde
entier sur des sites qui rivalisent
aussi d'infos et de réaction nicolas le
marigny 23h41 20 minutes à peine après
le décès de michael jackson ce n'est pas
une chaîne de télé mais un site internet
people qui annonce la nouvelle en
premier
immédiatement des milliers d'internautes
sont par des sites facebook et twitter
pour relayer l'information et témoigner
leur chagrin partout dans le monde
repose en paix michael jackson michael
jackson mon premier héros sur twitter
lire en perd la première place des
sujets de conversation entre minuit et
une heure du matin
2000 messages par minute alimente
l'hommage des vidéos comme celle ci il y
en a des dizaines sur youtube
aujourd'hui le site de partage est
devenue un immense lieu virtuel de
recueillement où les fans expriment leur
chagrin
deux jours avant mon anniversaire le mec
qui meurent quoi aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment une journée complète on le web
chinois s'y met en reprenant les vidéo
de cnn
en 24 heures les sites d'information ont
vu leur trafic augmenter de 50% la mort
de michael jackson ébranle aussi
internet
il est celui qui aura fait entrer la
musique noire dans les foyers blanc le
premier noir à être diffusé sur la
chaîne musicale mtv
précurseur dans tous les domaines
musique dans ce clip vidéo michael
jackson aura aussi passé sa vie à tenter
de devenir blanc et à faire oublier ses
origines
malgré cela il restera éternellement
l'étendard de la communauté
afro-américaine jérôme pernoo
un adieu le sourire aux lèvres en plein
coeur de harlem devant le théâtre apollo
le temple de la musique afro-américaine
des centaines de noirs viennent célébrer
l'un des leurs
il était là bien avant michael jordan un
beau mike tyson avant tout le monde
il était le plus grand de tous les temps
but reconnaissait pas mike tu ne
connaissais personne dans cette salle
michael jackson a fait ses grands débuts
il ya 42 ans il était l'enfant star de
la motown
la première maison de disques noirs dans
les années 60-70 une usine à tubes
dirigé par berry gordy était comme mon
fils il était chaleureux et sensible
avec lui la musique afro-américaine
entre comme jamais dans les foyers blanc
qu'est ce que ça lui aujourd'hui les
grandes figures de la communauté noire
michael jackson a fait que la culture
accepte une personne de couleur bien
avant tiger woods bien avant oprah
winfrey et bien avant le président
barack obama
michael a été à la musique ce qu'ils ont
été au sport à la télévision et à la
politique
et aucune controverse ne pourra effacer
cet impact historique
[ __ ] james blonde transmet les rênes
de la black music au roi de la pop
et pourtant michael jackson quitte la
moutarde pour une maison de disques
blanche sa peau s'éclaircit black or
white
peu importe répond chanteur
cette nuit harlem wire la communauté
noire se les réapproprier
et oui de michael jackson on retiendra
les déhanchements extraordinaire dès
1969 il a alors dix ans et se produit
avec ses frères au sein des jackson five
on se souviendra des tubes planétaires
agrémenté sur scène du moon walk inspiré
du mime marceau
mais l'histoire retiendra aussi
l'enfance fracassé le destin tragique
entre chirurgie esthétique phobies et
soupçons de pédophilie christophe airaud
revient pour nous sur la part d'ombré de
la star michael jackson à 10 ans il est
en scène c'est le plaisir d'un gamin
prodi mais pour lui
l'enfance ce n'est pas le paradis son
père joe est un tyran domestique il est
aussi son manager le petit michael est
un enfant humilier son père et pardonnez
moi c'est politiquement incorrect ce que
je vais dire mais le traitait de sale
[ __ ] avec un gros pif
donc vous imaginez le petit michael se
détestant physiquement ce qui se plie de
toutes ces transformations abominable
avec des chirurgiens esthétiques
californien il faudra mettre en prison
devenu adulte michael jackson se façonne
à nouveau virage
l'artiste noir se blanchit le nez
s'affine il n'ira la chirurgie
esthétique
mais les apparences ne trompe personne
recherche de la beauté perte d'identité
à cette époque michael jackson se crée
un personnage et danse avec les
morts-vivants pour échapper à ces
monstres dans la vraie vie michael
jackson se bâtit un refuge c'est
neverland
c'est une maison de poupée lilli aimera
bambi peter pan les contes et merveilles
mais l'attraction pour les enfants fini
en justice
1993 départ en attaque le chanteur pour
attouchements sexuels sur le fils de 13
ans 22 millions de dollars sont versés à
la famille et l'affairé corps et 2003
nouvelle plainte et cette fois s'il ya
procès la fiche n'est pas celle d'un
concert mais celle de la police il sera
acquitté
mais trouvera péniblement les montres se
défendre j'ai été récemment l'objet
d'accusations dégoûtant on me reproche
d'avoir une conduite déplacée ici ces
allégations sont totalement fausses
en 50 ans la face b du chanteur c'est
aussi deux mariages pour une presse
people qui se délecte 1994 il épouse
lisa marie presley fille un autre roi
celui du rock and roll sa seconde épouse
lui donnera deux enfants
les voici en promenade avec leur père
visage voilé et un après midi de 2002 à
berlin
présentation du petit troisième à la
presse et encore un scandale
ce fut une vie de star entre rêve et
réalité entre ce tracé désespoir une vie
qui se termine à hollywood une crise
cardiaque
interrompant ce destin tragique et enfin
en france autre réaction celle du tout
nouveau ministre de la culture frédéric
mitterrand se souvient d'un artiste
précisément douloureux dont le génie
aura été marquée à vif par le mal-être
on écoute puis à cette idée toujours
delà de l'adolescence perpétuelle
on sentait bien que michael jackson
avait acquis à posséder ce génie dès
l'enfance avait acquis cette maîtrise et
cette manière de l'exprimer au prix d'un
travail fantastique et d'une créativité
procès sic mais que sa compagne est
aussi depuis le début d'une d'une
incroyable souffrance douleur dans son
physique en perpétuelle transformation
dont les galères qui ont émaillé sa vie
sont révélateurs propos recueillis par
frédéric pasquette philippe manoeuvre
merci d'être resté avec nous vous avez
rencontré michael jackson c'était en
1987 racontez nous mais on voulait faire
une photo avec jean pierre rives qui
était le grand athlète le roi du parc
des princes jackson venait au parc des
princes et il a accepté cette demande
il est incroyablement contre toute
attente la maison dit disant voilà il
souhaite rencontrer ce grand champion ça
lui plaît bien et donc on est allé on
est resté 25 minutes dans sa loge avec
jean pierre rives et c'était très
difficile de c est le plus grand timide
un garçon d'une timidité incroyable qui
vivait vraiment dans un monde très
personnelle sa loge et 1,1 espèces d'un
entre deux poupées à capharnaüm avec des
jouets des choses pas très étrange
donc il était vraiment ce personnage
totalement irréel total mais reçoit
est-ce que c'est quelqu'un qui avait par
moments une vie normale des amis des
sorties il avait été pris en soule est
sous la bannière de toutes les grandes
stars du cinéma de hollywood steven
spielberg
elizabeth taylor audrey hepburn avant sa
disparition tout ça les dix mike hall c
était une star qui reconnaissait c'est
très très rare que les genres du cinéma
prennent sous leur aile quelqu'un qui
vienne de la musique mais lui avait
franchi ça il était considéré comme un
des leurs
pourquoi comment dernière question le
génie samba race et l'histoire de
l'homme à la cervelle d'or c'était le
premier clip billie jean c'était sale
histoire en fait c'est l'homme qui
grattent son cerveau qui donne l'heure à
tout le monde
puis à un moment il a plus rien un
moment il s'est laissé vrai que sa
production ces décès chez merci beaucoup
philippe manoeuvre d'avoir accepté notre
invitation donc merci
et france 2 rend hommage ce soir michael
jackson 23h10 dans un jour un destin
laurent delahousse reviendra sur la
légende merci beaucoup
dans le reste de l'actualité de ce
vendredi nicolas sarkozy est arrivé en
début de soirée la guadeloupe après un
séjour de plusieurs heures à la
martinique où il était très attendu sur
l'avenir institutionnel de l'île juste
avant son départ de fort-de-france pour
répondre au malaise social qui persiste
le chef de l'état a proposé un
référendum sur l'autonomie en martinique
michaël darmon et josé vous les sexes
sont nos envoyés spéciaux réparer le
passé en dévoilant la plaque de
l'aéroport de fort de france nicolas
sarkozy fait sienne la formule d'aimé
césaire le poète martiniquais
en martinique la république ville sur un
volcan mais dans le hall de l'aéroport
le maire et le chef de l'état parlent
ensemble d'un nouveau départ réclamé
depuis longtemps
il est temps d'oeuvrer à l'avènement de
cet autre monde que ses airs de vinay la
martinique autonome est prête à y
prendre toute sa part le débat dont nous
parlons n'est pas celui de
l'indépendance
il ne s'agit pas d'organiser à mes yeux
subrepticement un je ne sais quel
largage de la république
le débat qui est ouvert est celui du
juste degré d'autonomie la martinique
sera autonome
si la population le décide
avec la mode
quelle date nous allons parler
maintenant avec les c'est lui je vais
passer particulier à poursuivre les
consultations comme je lé fais attend
comme vous l'avez vu un très grand
consensus entre la martinique et la
guadeloupe les revendications ne sont
pas les mêmes à pointe à pitre on aurait
qu'un pas plus de tenue et plus de
pouvoir d'achat ils madrelle accueille
bien organisée à l'aéroport
les émeutes de février ont laissé des
traces 2il de réalité mais une même
demande une meilleure reconnaissance des
antilles dans la communauté nationale
en guadeloupe il ya eu 44 jours de grève
générale cette année
nicolas sarkozy va chercher à se
réconcilier avec les guadeloupéens
depuis près de trois mois maintenant la
ville de hénin beaumont dans le pas de
calais n'a plus de maire depuis que
celui ci a été mise en examen pour
détournement de fonds publics et placé
en détention une élection municipale
partielle a lieu dimanche et selon les
derniers sondages c'est le front
national avec marine le pen auréolé de
son succès aux européennes dans la
région qui serait en tête
thierry curtet david almeida l'hôtel de
ville n'a plus de locataires monsieur le
maire est en prison pour corruption
les derniers patrons de l'usiné
samsonite sont aussi en prison a eu pour
détournement de fonds
280 au chômage les deux histoires n'ont
pas de lien mais la faillite de ses
élites créer un climat délétère ici où
le chômage atteint 10 9%
une situation qui profite au front
national dans un récent sondage
il arrive largement en tête 35% devant
deux listes socialistes loin derrière
marine le pen est ici colistière de
steeve briois
si steve bénéficie n'atteigne la cape
town confiance c'est parce que il a
acquis ce capital confiance parce qu'il
la méritait il a été absolument le seul
à le faire c'est d'avoir le courage à
pugnacité la persévérance de combattre
une hypothèque était une municipalité
avec un fonctionnement mafieux
ici la gauche qui à la ville depuis la
libération le candidat officiel ps pc
modem n'a que 27 ans pierre ferrari a
été élu avec l'ancien maire
même s'il s'est très tôt des marques et
du coup il a un peu de mal à parler du
passé parler du passé elle se préoccupe
pas de l'avenir de la commune - suscite
un engouement et une commune d'avenir de
futurs moi je pense à nos enfants censés
l'ancien maire avait ses opposants à
gauche aussi ses dissidents socialistes
veulent maintenant leur revente
daniel duquenne talonne la liste
officielle mais ces divisions inquiète
et sympathisants le premier temps les
forces en présence
à gauche on évoqua front républicain
pour le deuxième tour guy bout des
lèvres seulement on avait vous découvrez
sur vos écrans toutes les listes en
présence pour cette élection municipale
de hénin-beaumont la gay pride
sillonnera demain les rues de paris le
cortège fête cette année les 40 ans de
la lutte homosexuels une lutte contre
les discriminations qui persistent dans
la société et notamment dans le monde de
l'entreprise selon une étude de la halde
66 % des salariés homosexuels éviterait
de le dire à leurs patrons témoignages
recueillis par aurélia bros et eric de
laignes assumer son homosexualité au
travail n'est pas si facile
certaines entreprises commencent donc à
y prêter attention ici un réseau gay
soutenue par la direction fait dans la
pédagogie auprès des salariés
sexuel une femme dans une entreprise
c'est quand même de parler de sa vie
privée c'est d'être devant la machine à
café et donc de pouvoir raconter ce
qu'on a fait pendant le week-end sans
avoir la priory à bon tu es parti avec
tes enfants tu es parti avec ta femme
comment va ta petite amie oui oui bah
non il s'appelle jules on nous bombarde
c'est des sujets dont on ne parle pas
forcément facilement et puis même entre
nous sur les gars n'a pas toujours
beaucoup d'infos donc
donc oui je pense est un progrès à faire
l'entreprise et c'est bien en parler
aujourd'hui christophe jeunes ont fait
trop ouvertement partie du réseau gay de
l'entreprise mais pendant des années il
a caché une partie de sa vie
la dissimuler au travail moi quand j'ai
appris l'existence du réseau idole ya
déjà quelques années
ça m'a été ça m'a enlevé un énorme quoi
parce que je passais mon temps à zélé
murat pas être trop sûr que les gens
voulaient pas que ça se sache si plus de
la moitié des homosexuels évite de le
dévoiler au travail c'est peut-être
parce que 80% d'entre eux disent avoir
été confronté au moins une fois à de
l'homophobie
même si elle est souvent implicite ça va
se manifester de manière beaucoup plus
sophistiqué par départ des comportements
éloignés par d une distance
on constate également des difficultés à
progresser dans la carrière
parler d'homosexualité dans son
entreprise n'est pas toujours aussi
facile pour pascal l'homophobie a pris
un visage plus agressif sous les traits
de son patron en 2004 il est en cdd
depuis un an dans un bureau d'études ne
cache pas son homosexualité il ne
l'affichent pas non plus un jour son
patron l'a prend dès qu'il a su j'ai été
convoqué dans son bureau médiatement
pour parler de ma vie privée s'est-il
justifié sur à saint vallier pro b
pourquoi je ne vais pas parler plus tôt
après cet entretien son cdd n'a pas été
reconduit faute de contrats disponibles
lui at on expliqué
40% des homosexuels 10 comme lui avoir
été victimes d'actes homophobes au
travail
quatre écoles fermées aujourd'hui dans
plusieurs villes des hauts-de-seine en
région parisienne où on soupçonne
plusieurs cas de grippe a chez des
enfants les établissements ont été
fermées pour une durée d'au moins quatre
jours dans l'essonne une école a été
également fermée après la découverte de
3,4 dans la même classe et on signale ce
soir un autre cas dans le morbihan on
compte désormais en france 239 cas
confirmés tepa est aujourd'hui le oms
fait état de près de soixante mille cas
dans le monde
263 morts au total le tennis à wimbledon
défaite de jo-wilfried tsonga éliminé au
troisième tour par ivo karlovic victoire
en quatre sets pour le croate 7 6 6 7 7
5 7 6 il est qualifié pour les huitièmes
de finale
une libellule géante de 63 mètres
d'envergure l'apparence d'un gros avion
de ligne mais un poids proche de celui
d'une voiture
voici un engin qui pourrait bien
révolutionner l'aviation après six
années de recherche
l'explorateur bertrand piccard
présentait aujourd'hui le prototype d'un
avion solaire avec lequel il souhaite
faire le tour du monde
nicolas chateauneuf mathias barrois un
concentré de technologie poussée à
l'extrême
voici le prototype de solar himpens avec
son aile géante qui ne semble jamais
finir
le résultat de six ans de recherches
pour l'équipe du suisse bertrand piccard
avec l'idée de réaliser un rêve un peu
fou le tour du monde en avion uniquement
grâce à l'énergie solaire
un défi technique rendue possible par
douze mille cellules photovoltaïques
situés sur les ailes pour réaliser que
c'est un navire qui a la taille au
niveau envergure d'un airbus 340 car le
poids d'une voiture 1600 kg et qui
doivent donner avec l'énergie d'un petit
scooter plus personne ensuite ne pourra
venir prétendre qu'on ne peut pas
utiliser des énergies renouvelables pour
des voitures pour des bateaux pour des
maisons pour espérer faire voler cela
rime pulse il a fallu traquer le moindre
gramme superflu utiliser des matériaux
en fibre de carbone et inventer de
nouveaux instruments de navigation
car l'avion sera très compliquée à
piloter les très grands yvonne lentement
illettrés les ai donc on fait toutes ces
manoeuvres sont très lentes donc le
pilote quand il initie une à une
manoeuvre pour qu'ils aient beaucoup de
patience aussi la tente de voir qu'est
ce qui va se passer
les essais auront lieu dans les
prochains mois avant les premiers vols
de nuit sur batterie avec un budget de
65 millions d'euros sur fonds privés un
second avion sera ensuite construit
celui qui tentera le tour du monde en
cinq étapes voilà pour l'essentiel je
vous rappelle la principale information
de ce vendredi 26 juin la mort de
michael jackson c'est une crise
cardiaque qui a emporté la star
planétaire
hier à los angeles et alors qu'on
attendait depuis près de 24 heures elle
la réaction du président américain
barack obama elle vient de tomber à
l'instant
jackson était une icône mais à la vie
tragique c'est ce que vient de déclarer
par la voix d'un porte parole de la
maison blanche le président des états
unis je vous le disais tout à l'heure
aux mages de france 2 ce soir à 23h10 un
jour un destin présenté par laurent
delahousse mais dans un instant votre
série central nuit je vous souhaite une
très bonne soirée
merci de votre attention
m
aux yeux
oh
toi
m
elle me dit ouais
oui
m
toute une course 2